okay as in Kardashian that's my girl I  would love if you could just sing a  couple of these for us I will give it a  go there is nothing I would like more in  life do peanuts half corpse do peanuts  have car gear that's good that's good do  peanuts have cars do peanuts help Karma  baba Baba barber barber herbs Nicole  Richie reminds me of my Jeep Nicole  Richie reminds me of my GE babe huh what  what even mean Nicole Richie reminds me  of a Jeep someone has a cavity in the  carbon I can smell it someone has a  cavity in my car I can smell it see  that's why you have myths yes history  she says she has a special power she  could smell cavities a little kid just  cuffed literally in my face on a plane  it is rude I said sweetie please cover  your swiney I'm not about to get sick a  sexy aspire to inspire aspire to inspire  aspire to inspire spires to inspire  before you expire Wow haha Taylor Swift  see you soon as the Oscar Grammy Tony's